dass soziale medien wie facebook und co
alle wirklich alle daten über ihre
nutzer sammeln ist nichts neues
doch auch diejenigen unter euch die
nichts mit solchen plattformen armut
damals auch gar nicht angemeldet sind
sind vor diesen daten kragen ganz und
gar nicht sicher
ein forschungsteam aus der schweiz hat
nun konkrete hinweise auf sogenannte
schatten profile gefunden und ja ihr
habt richtig vorhersagen über sehr
private details wie zum beispiel
sexuelle interessen oder aktueller
beziehungsstatus sind damit möglich und
zwar von nichtnutzern wie social media
nutzer also die privatsphäre derjenigen
preis geben die offline leben und wofür
genau auch vielleicht eure daten
missbraucht werden könnten
jetzt klingt zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
man könnte manchmal fast denken dass
facebook noch vor einem selbst weiß
welche personen man gut finden welches
neue hobby man demnächst ausprobieren
möchte oder welche reise als nächstes
ansteht teilweise ist das schon fast
unheimlich wie gut soziale medien ihre
nutzer kennen und natürlich auch kein
stück verwunderlich bei den ganzen daten
die man bei sozialen medien wie facebook
und co über sich selbst preisgibt
privatsphäre hd möchte man das nicht und
seine daten schützen meldet man sich
eben nicht an so könnte man meinen das
stimmt aber nicht
denn was von uns im internet bekannt ist
entscheiden wir längst nicht mehr selbst
sondern diejenigen in unserem freundes
und bekanntenkreis die sozialen medien
nutzen 2013 ist dass allen das erste mal
richtig klar geworden da musste facebook
eine riesige sicherheitslücke
eingestehen oder ich sag mal ein feature
konkret konnten user an die kontakte von
nicht freundin gelangen es war sogar
noch krasser selbst telefonnummern und
e-mail-adressen von leuten die noch
niemals bei facebook angemeldet gewesen
waren wurden teilweise preisgegeben und
für facebook ist es keine kunst an die
daten von nichtnutzern zu gelangen
im gegenteil denn alle die facebook den
zugriff auf ihre persönlichen e mail
dienste erlauben geben diese kontakte
frei facebook lädt sich dann die
digitalen telefonbücher seiner nutzer
herunter dieses phänomen also wenn
informationen über nicht nutzer
gesammelt werden nennen experten eben
schatten profile und genau dazu hat
jetzt ein forscher aus der schweiz
weitere brisante hinweise gesammelt
für seine studie hat er die plattform
namens friends tagen und sie ist zwar
stillgelegt unzählige accounts lassen
sich aber weiterhin im archiv
analysieren hier wollte er herausfinden
ob sich aussagen über leute treffen
lassen die dort nicht angemeldet sind
und die antwort lautet ganz klar ja in
seinem experiment analysiert in der
forschung zum beispiel inwiefern
bestimmte persönliche merkmale vom
fenster usern mit denen ihrer kontakte
zusammenhängen beispielsweise fand er so
heraus dass heterosexuelle er mit dem
jeweils anderen geschlecht in kontakt
stehen homosexuelle vernetzen sich
dagegen häufiger mit nutzern die
dasselbe gewicht haben die sie selbst so
entstanden
in seiner studie statistische musste
natürlich für weitere unterschiedliche
faktoren und diese wiederum würden es in
diesem fall bei fenster erlauben relativ
unkompliziert ein schatten profil zu
konstruieren von einer person die eben
kein nutzer ist relativ treffsicher
könnten antworten auf fragen wie wie ist
die sexuelle orientierung von personen
xy oder wie ist der beziehungsstatus von
personen xy beantwortet werden sehr
intime informationen also die die
menschen wahrscheinlich lieber für sich
behalten würden die treffsicherheit für
solche aussagen stieg in der
schweizerischen studie übrigens mit der
anzahl der nutzer die sich bei der
plattform vernetzt hatten und ja klar je
mehr daten die user über sich selbst
preisgeben desto sicherer wurde die
prognose zu daten derjenigen die nicht
mal selbst dort angemeldet haben der
schweizerische forscher sagt selbst dass
seine ergebnisse sicher auch auf andere
plattformen wie facebook beispielsweise
zu übertragen sein erfordert deswegen
dass regelungen zum datenschutz dieses
phänomens der schatten profile mehr
berücksichtigt werden müssen aber auch
wir selbst können unsere schlüsse daraus
ziehen denn mittlerweile ist es oft
nicht mehr so dass man apps den vollen
zugriff auf alle daten gewähren muss an
dieser stelle könnte man beispielsweise
die ziele auswählen denn um das kann sie
noch einmal auf den punkt zu bringen
das recht auf privatsphäre wird hier
komplett ignoriert nicht ich selbst habe
also die entscheidung in der hand möchte
ich persönliche infos weitergeben oder
nicht das entscheidend stattdessen die
anderen für mich und das auch noch ohne
sich darüber im klaren zu sein und so
werde ich darüber natürlich auch nicht
informiert oder gar um erlaubnis gefragt
die chance sich dagegen zu wehren ist
also gleich null geht gar nicht vor
allem wenn man bedenkt dass diese daten
sicher nicht unbedingt vertraulich
behandelt werden und uns allen ist klar
daten sind viel wert nicht umsonst gibt
es aussagen wie daten sind das neue öl
und
zahlreiche geschäftsmodelle die daten
für viel geld kaufen gibt es ja
inzwischen zum beispiel für marketing
oder auch politische kampagnen und wenn
plötzlich institutionen wie
krankenkassen behörden oder arbeitgeber
alles aber auch wirklich alles über uns
wissen könnte dass unsere gesellschaft
komplett verändern ja wenn ihr keinen
video zu diesem thema verpassen wollt
und auch zu allen anderen spannenden
themen dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht den genau auf
die glocke hier geht es weiter mit also
hier bakterien als datenspeicher das
geht tatsächlich wie dass er vater im
video und ansonsten bis dann bleibt